[Music]  Jago do you think you'll cry a lot on  the show I'm not a big crowd no how many  women will you kiss on night one you're  known as the kissing bandit I'm gonna  keep that little under lock and key yeah  I think I'm gonna be selective on that  what are your tips for being the kissing  bandit how do you kiss a woman properly  always have good brother okay timing  kiss is all about timing and you have to  know that the other person wants to  because it's always how important our  first impressions to you a lot of people  end up with the person that give that  first impression rose to yeah that's  huge I would say you know chemistry's  big for me will you propose at the end  of all this I hope so  [Music]